so our Nexter is Fran from Andr
thank you so today I'm going to talk
about STR spity so many of different
definitions of that so in that talk I
will focus mostly on situations where I
want to estimate SP vectors Spar vector
but I want zeros  to Organize in some way
so in other words I don't want to be
invariant by permutation i want to
impose some structure
and this
has many cases and particular the group
case
if estimated which organ in groups
the Group group penalty are used for
this in  this talk I want to do this very
systematically give me some prior
knowledge into your dat I will construct
a nor to do so so this will be the
outline of my talk so will first
provuction
tow and the of
if norm is toond nor and this take  talk
and this responds most to situations where
you want to dovised learning and I will
also spend one of the talk dealing with
unsvised learning you want to learn some
new
representations similar way that John
was presenting earlier earlier today so
first part structur you want to some
zeros  second part I look at
matrixorizations
so a bit of notation first i'm going to
consider SuperV learning where have some
data XI in RP and
some response Yi and I to predict y y
from x and I'm going to consider the
regularized risk minimization when  I
want to
minimize convex data fitting term so in
this talk squ for simplicity and also
add panaler Omega and I'm going to SP so
this has been studied a lot by people in
the room and many reasons to do so there
are several names
B  this is typically used for two reasons
so the first one is interpretability so
in a sense spcity is a proxy for
interpretation you can simply look at
the features which were used for your
prediction and this is this is often
important in practice and this I will
focus  a lot on that in this talk and
also you can do high dimensal inference
so P can be larger than n as long as log
P is less
so can do learning with SIM techniques
di learning as was presented by
John so you assume that you have
different responses okay
responses set of of signals and if you
know your design matrix x or dictionary
then you might want to decompose all of
your responsesing dictionary this diary
is given can estimate the dictionary x
and corresponds to minimizing both with
respect to x and to W
so it's often seen in the context ofal
processing
the problem on on
dictionary elements you don't want
any structure on dictionary elements and
this is of dictionary learning and this
has been done by several
people already one thing I want to
really mention is that dictionary is
simply the transpose of Spar PC okay
so typically in Spar PCA you want to put
SP dictionary elements and don't put any
structure in the coefficients
essentially those are the two same
so why do you want to additional
structure the first reason to me is
interpretability so let's look at a
simple
example  let's say you want to do a SP
PCA on Fa so let's say you have like a
bunch of faces like like here like a
thousand faces and you do Spar PC so you
want to decompose every new face with
sub dictionary elements and you want to
put  some sparity on the dictionary
element this is what you obtain on the
right so here gre is zero and black and
white are
large non zero value and to you those
bas
vectors so here in green gre the screen
you get the set the set of zeros okay  so it
is a situation where we have a lot of
zeros but this does not mean that you
can really interpret the result in a
simple way
so here in that setup what we will try
to do is to use the structure of the
problem so here you  have a 2D problem
and ideally you would like your non
zeros to
appear some localized way this is what
we are going to do just changing one TER
the formulation replacing the L1 by
something else the goal is to get
something like this where now the nons
the non  zeros are are convex shapes in
the plane so the main theme of the talk
is give give me some pri knowledge of my
problem how can I build a norm to
achieve achieve
this then this is also important for
other reasons first stability so it's
well known that  the L1 L1 penalty does
not lead to stable results in terms of
the vector W and you might want to use
extra structure to make this more stable
and of course if you impose pr knowledge
which matches your the statistical
problem you should predict better and
this I  won go too much into it are many
reasons why you want to use structur
model on top of interpability
so there are many types of structure
okay so I'm sure there are more than
this but typically there are three main
types of structure that people have been
working on zeros okay and you want to
organize in a certain way I'm going to
talk about this but people have also
consider special structure in level sets
okay soed total variation and
essentially what talk about today can be
extended to that case as well I W
mention it and finally this will be the
last part of the talk you can also
not caring much zer but factorizing
matrix with structure for all of the the
factors and this be the end
of okay so so here are many ways of
attacking the problem many  applications
have looked which have presented here in
vision neuro imaging and so on of course
you can do this in a noncvex way okay in
fact the first approach to do this with
gr methods ok and it works already very
well
but talk
formula
me try to design  a new
norm do a lot is to look at norms and
their
BS unit BS so here on the left have L2
norm no corners on the middle norm so
you
havem and here this is one example of
the group of the group l norm whichfic
set of
singularities
so let's look first at what is the L1
norm so of the L1 norm is the absolute
values ​​obvious but also a bit more so
what you can you can see the L1 norm as
being the best convex approximation of
the L penalty ok so hereuce notations  V
will always be my set of predictors so V
to P I the support of W so W vector it
support set of nonzero
components l l penalty is simply the
cinality of the support ok so here if if
you look in ok if look in theer penalty
has zero  value in zero and is one
everywhere else so if you want to
replace this by conve function and you
to want to be
belowenalty and if you
vevelty very well known the goal of to
to show that if you replinality by
something else want to put addal the  and
this will be done different
function then you can
do
so this to do toption the we cannot do
this for all possible
function so any so a set function which
goes from subsets okay all
possible subsets to real numbers ok I
assume it is noncreasing you want  to
penal larger subsets and I will also
assume that it
is I will this all us to do all the
andiorm
Andys so first what
isity ok so you have several ways
ofingity so remember F is function
subset andity means that if you take any
two subsets  A and B F+ F B is greater F
plusure
just below for any if you isolate any
any single element K the cost
of adding K to any a is decreasing in
a this notion of diishing return
ofition
fact if you take aun which is a set
function  which depends only on the on
the cinality then it is as soon as g con
ok so you have nice relationship with
concavity but in terms of behavior and
analysis it behaves more like conve
functions the
mainas that you can minimize them in and
relationship with conity which  I
describe l so here of
course of course this been already used
quite quite a bit Inal processing and
machine learning particular uh the total
variation which corresponds to to cuts
and also by to do optimal design because
the log de as will see the log de is  log
de of sub matrix is ​​a sub function so
the classical examples that people have
considered i've already talked about
concave functions of cardinality CS gra
C
gra a a and a is entropies if if you
take P any P rom variables you the
entropy of the  subset of variables index
by a it's is and also if you take g
variabl log dat of arix is ​​you have
network flows this is very useful in
terms for efficient algorithms and also
r functions of matroid but I won use
all the
manying function way I i  like to see
them is the relationship with convexity
ok so if you take first any set function
f ok so essentially you can identify the
set of subsets by vertices of the hyper
cube so this is done there any subset
can bepped to vert of the hper so  any
set function
hper
givenun to
H in fact integral is doing but of the
integr iser to the extension in that set
so you take any W
so it can be the hyper in any any places
in the RP you order components this n
log time and then  you define
function l extension as
piecewise linear function this ok and if
you look very if you look very carefully
this corresponds to cutting that H cube
in simplies and doing interpolation it's
not statement this is what what's
happening so why is it extension because
if you are  vertex of the hyper cube you
recover the function so F
oficator vector is the value of the
function OK so essenti we're going to do
is see all set functions exension so is
it soce because
essentiallyity of the set function is
equivalent to conity of the  lov
extension this is by by Lovas the 8 ok
on top of that if you want to minim the
function ok so minim the L ex the vertic
of H can this
so this is one the reas why you
cantim fun in poomal so I W do this so
much in the talk a lot of nice links
betweenity and
convexity go back
to want to design a new penalty to
induce spity and I
tox of the F Tak support the goal is
this fun th which will be my
knowledge predictors and I Tove a convex
lower  bound namely the conve envelope
and what you can show that if the convex
envelope of that function is essentially
the l extension taken at the absolute
values ​​of the components so just as a
safety check if F is the
cinality the l extension of components
and you recover  exactly ear the L1 nor
the conve Envel
Ofen this now you can whenever deing
with such a function you can look at a
conve so at the end all
those norms are since F the l extension
is fine all the norms are polyhedral and
all the unit bols  are are polytops ok so
here I an example in in
so any function and if IAL to some
function get back the L1 norm Infinity
norm and this is a group this is
another norm so you can show several
results on the problem so I won give  all
of them the first one is the notion of
stability ok so set a stable ok if if
you want if you increase a to something
bigger you have to increase F as
well if you minimize something like
this you
will ort why because if not St can always
bit of W ok you can always decrease the
loss but you will not increase the
function so the sense you can only
achieve stable subsets when you consider
capital this function which is hard to
optimize and what you show that if you
replace F by the L exension  like this
youerve so one exle
Ofer
and so some further examples this is
3dinity norm you get the then you get
with many points and if you look this
care the L1
infinitym group norm where you have some
norm have a group of size and GRP of
siinity  which sub case of our result and
even more more
complex let's look at some cl let's look
closer at some examples try to see if we
gain anything by by looking at all
possible sub functions so we do in two
directions take existing norms and see
them through  subular eyes and do the
opposite take a new sub function and try
to see that it does lead to an
interesting regularizer so the first
thing i'm going to consider is
l Infinity where
you of subsets here h and I take for all
elements of capital  h h I will take W my
vector restrict it to that group WG and
infinitym so if h is a partition of one P
this recovers exactly the the group
linity can sit have a partition this was
looked at both by and you and also by my
student essentially  those norms were
first designed in terms of supports if
you consider the L1 Infinity norm so the
case where h is a partition this will
select groups of variables ok if you
select a variable in a group you will
select the entire group so one way ofing
this sort  more the complement of
supp have to be union of groups the
reason the reason because when you minim
this you will to P to push some of the
to zero so you create some zeros for
certain
WG groups g so at the end the set of
zeros is  a union of those groups so the
support is a complement of
thisort
is ok it so let look at some examples
and so here thisresounds to function
which will do what which will simply
take a set a and count the number of
group G which has nonero intersection  ok
so if you take partition if h is a
partition this gives veryal
interpretation of the L Infinity norm
namely that you want only as soon as you
have one group it doesn't cost you
anything to add full group of our here
theable
a select groups groups  all together so
here key aspect here is
that our the new formulation allows you
to go beyond simply counting subsets ok
in fact our first work on doing using
those were only based on what are the
patterns which you
can this new formulation allows you to
haveer interpretation  you put a prior on
all subsets some of them will be
forbidden but for all of them you have a
cost and this and I won give any too
much details can be used to refine a bit
the problem so let's look at a very
simple example so  if you consider
variables which are organized in a line
so here five variables and you use as
groups all the groups which are which
are blue here and here so if you Panal
with the norms with norm based on that
group you will put
zer some theiabl BL  groupsend if you put
any of the blue here of the blue here to
zer what you left with with non zeros
are variables which are in a sequence ok
the nonero have to be contiguous so this
you can show of course formally and you
can extend to other  other topology so
now if
you in fact you can that that with of
group that set of group the function so
your prior on subset essentially the R
of the subset that you select so
essentially you you put a prior that you
want subset with small small range  you
can go from 1D to 2D ok by considering
all like all by all rectangles on the
right left top and bottom again if you
put to zero any of those groups what
you're left with as non zero is
rectangle in the middle so here of
course you don't know what the rectangle
is and this will be found
automa byorm from this you can to more
ang then you canve any conve shapes in
the plane essentially this is what we
have used in the context of SP PC ok so
of SP  PCA we have consider dictionary
PCA problem when you want to factorize
the matrix y with all your signals as x W
be done by
just changing the L1 this group
group so this is what you obtain with on
the left with Spar PCA so the zeros are
the zeros are scattered all over the
place and as soon as you impose this
localized constraint then the zeros
in con shapes  so of course is pure
subjective just beautiful i think
beauful but in the paper we
quanaluationsowing that
theentations from
dictionary for doingn
so it's
not can be usimilar framework
yes
oh you mean here maybe the top
left
so so you ask very good
question Hiden under the carpet  is the
that you need some some some weights
inside those norms to avoid reallyening
too much the corners
ok
l l we
s to
more liciting when
have Infinity norm by the L2 norms then
you there a lot of overcounting all over
the place and with Infinity norm is not
the case anymore and with that
interpretation you can really avoid
those painful issues it's clearly a
problem practice you want to avoid that
what you to make you to make that if
sign over there ok then you
can our sol here this ise ok so you have
which  isose the and you
can India of in
prtice let this so this was one
direction
so
and l F
whicher and try to see
ifting so one interesting example and I
W have time to present it is to look at
entropies of subsets
so so if you haveri typically  all the
norm that people have been
designing for SP recovery do notend on
the
des of the
Vect des now depends on the designri with
the capital x and we have and also have
extensions with ED andsk where this
improves a bit in terms of
recovery so let's  look at some unified
algorithms and analysis so first all our
nors are polyhedral okay so you can be a
big LP the number of faces and
verticesig so you work you can design
subadient easily because can design the
subgradient of the l extension but this
is still too  slow and what I want to
present now is really a nice link
between optimization and continuous
optimization so for for that I will
consider proximal methods okay so these have
been already discussed this
workshop if you want to minimize the sum
of differentiable function typically a
square  loss or logistic loss plus your
regularizer then you can you can have
very efficient algorithm ok which are
esstially gradient descent if you can
solve those problems efficiently which
is proximal problem so when OMA is norm
this is S throlding and it turns out
that for all the  norms which I'm
considering you can solve that that
problem efficiently and it has some nice
links with function minimization ok so
this is in fact first done by
byambbon ok so let
ation
W that if sol of that gu ok then sol of
those
and
min  F
of
F
this means that if you want to that guy
you can do it by sequence of such
function mination and
this you can do it by
numberaty
Nice l between optimization
and timization so of course it works much
faster than methods so this very very
basic simulations  since the proximal
step is efficient you can really improve
on
subgadient in terms of analysis so I
won't give any any details but you can
have a unified analysis of
thatesstially if you know how to with L
norm and if you know how to deal with  L1
l Infinity norm and if you the NAS paper
by neabal you discover that the only
thing that you need to prove anything
for Spar recovery or for
also estimation guarantees is to be able
to decompose the norm
piece on the support and a piece outside
of the  support it turns out that in our
setup we do have we do have partial
decomposability and this is enough to
extend all results of neg metal and
of so I W giveails because it's few
slides but the end recover the results
of
ab one right which was for L1  and
Infinity but extend to all possible
cases okay so you have unified analysis
but I W give too much
details so a few a few caviats to
that framework and the first one this
really was a big problem for me that I
don't like Infinity norms  ok so I don't
like Infinity norms because they have
some extra behaviors so if you take the
L Infinity norm okay so this
corresponds to that function so this is
not supposed to have any spfying effect
at least when I when I play around with
my  sub function there is no spacity
involved but it has some extra corners
there's no blocking at zeros but you
have some blocking at vectors of equal
magnitudes so this is typical
sometimes nature method
to you extra constraints and if you
don't want them not going to work  this
is for L1 and Infinity if you consider
the Group group L1 then you have this
this square is not is not useful this is
one one limitation the other limitation
is that you only care can only deal with
functions of our many situations you to
beyond functions sosk  and I have worked
on that trying to remove those those
problems and go quickly on this and have
simply consider the new norm
so if you know about very classical
toess nor weed L2 norm okay so if you
put F being the sum of components then
this is  to recover the L1 if ma minim et
then etly the absolute value of W
can
F
canaceity by any function it also
defines norm
you can show that norm some
convepretationsely now the con Envel of
what
notunctionl con
toin
enaling
Anding that if to find the convex
envelope  of that guy or the homogeneous
conve envelope of that guy you recover
exactly that function
ok you can extend
to Q and P different from two you can
replace l by if you want the key set
is and if you use that nor the unit B of
those
over
grouingous and some the problem that
were some the extra corners which were
created by the
infinityinity so here so esstially if
you don't like infinity and you should
be right not to like Infinity then you
can use
L2
so this was for SP tring toose  some
structures on the zeros of your problem
for the last part of the talk I have
three slides okay so it's going to be to
be quick to go beyond simply like
having sets of zeros and try to be as
systematic okay but for matrix
factorizations so  what we to consider
going to consider matrix x of size n D
and we want we want to decompose sum of
factors so the factors umvm we will
constra them to BES
so typically SP small number of nonero
elements belonging to zer one or
positivity okay any any  possible set not
be convex you can can deal with anything
so here the goal is give me x I to
recover singular value decomposition but
now I to
con here responds to a lot of unning
problems if you take what
is essentially so this is
clustering responds to being only  zer and
OK nongative
matorizationrespond to and V being non
negative
can
sorry so just to just to restrict B the
only cases for that for the talk That
UNV are unit BS so not consider
positivity just consider belonging to
unit B L1 L2 and so on now
define  a norm x ok so define the nor Tha
on x which will be the infimum over
all possible
decompositions of
for factors so this
firsteveral which you can show number
the rank can be less can be alwaysosen
to be l
simpleate argument th is norm new norm
in fact work on that with j and
up for few so why is it already done
because if you look at  the dual norm th
th
this
one
matum over u y
are considering to do mat decomosition
Isly the dual norm of an existing norm
and even worse this already has a name
it's called summing norms by James and
in fact this dates back to this Joel TR
told me  this it dates back to Grot in
the 50 or 60 i don't know so at the end
this is all very old and it's it's also
an instance of an atomic nor I think the
next by Ben cover this is corresponds to
anomic
so let let's  look at some special cases
because it's a nice norm but it turns
out we can never compute it so source of
big disappointment it's already done
plus you can't compute it except in two
cases when one of the norms is L1 norm
okay so then you  get back a group L1
norm it's not super useful there is no
decomposition in that setup and of
course if you have the two being the L2
norm break over the nuclear which is
welln so on top those two cases and a
few others which it complic i don  't know
any possibility I don't any clpressions
so what going to do is quickly find some
relaxations ok for either Tha or du norm
and of course and this is the only novty
in what I'm presenting not only you want
to relax the  value
B lower band you want to be able to
recover decompositions you really want
give me Matri x me
factors so in terms of relaxation so we
going to very
standardfin relaxations so take the case
where much
simpler then I can consider the dual
norm ok it's a  max over u which is my
unit my set of factors
Times max over the L to norm and you can
maximize in close form with respect to
to V and you get the maximum of
quadratic function of you and of
course as you going to relax it  by
considering the set of transpos which I
call capital u and then you can design a
lot of relaxations of that set transpose
for example there are two different sets
which you can use with certain
guarantees so go is not to go too much
the details you can
designfin relaxations for all of those
norms okay some with constant factors
and this this were first done by nester
and grotend in in the 40s and also in
some other cases as well as
that not sufficient to be able to
compute bander band on the dualm you
want  to able to recover the
decomposition and this you can do by a
certain form of conditional gradient
algorithm essentially you can recast the
problem as what I have a bunch of
vectors
will be the factors ui VI
transpose and you want to approximate
Vect xination of those el with
minim and const positivity so this is
what you need to solve the catch is that
I be infinite I is very large not allow
to
do because you
cannot accept entire vector  alpha and
what you can only do caness yourili
vectors by
maxingction ok and those vectors so this
corresponds in my setup to maximizing the
dual norm to computing the dual norm and
it that this has been done also by other
other colleagues that if you only know
something  like this you canover your
your decomposition okay using a form of
G algorithm this is really related to G
algorithm and if you want to know more
you can come talk to me after the talk
so to conclude so I presented two sets
work one which is on  tring to some
struct on zer and TR to do it in a
systematic and this was done
throughularity so there are of course a
lot of things which are missing and to
me the most important to me is high You
should find that function so this rel to
the question of Emmanuel there are a lot
of hyper parameters start to deal with
those problems and you want to estimate
those directly from this is
Carly as well for the matrix
decompositions there is one aspect i
think which is a bit disappointing a
general con framework it's  nice and
convex not computable but you can have
relaxations but the mosting aspect is
that empally in all my experiments it
has not been able to beat existing
simpler methods so the method that John
was referring to
alternatingtimization you to factorize x
in V transpose so when fixed  in so just
alternate has no
guaranteessoever this behaves
surprisingly well and my hope by doing
this was to be able to get guarantees
but been a failure for the
last
years but I'm still hopeful and last
point I think there is nice work I think
the original work on atomic norms
by
wasing recovery
guarantees this was not
all fact in particular so here the goal
is to take the of John which is
dictionary learning whichond to two
factors one SP one non and to make i
want to make sure that I recover  it so
this is not the case for the moment and
methods bas not
basationble
TOS
to ation thank you for your
atttion HM
I the
to
designriort and which forgotten very
important and typically when yous you
want to adapts to comination of designri
and
V
if
not
and  this will not help a lot so the key
aspect is tring to design the analysis
for specific dictionaries for images